In this video,
we're going to be showing you
some of the cool things
that you can do
with UV activated ink.
And thanks to Audible
for sponsoring this video.
[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
[Music]
This is what we've got in mind:
We'll take our UV ink pens
and our UV ink in a bottle,
and we'll try writing,
painting, and spraying the ink
onto several different surfaces.
We'll see which
ones show up the best,
which one's glow best
under a black light,
and which ones seem
the most permanent.
To test this out, we have
a few different methods.
We have a couple of ballpoint
pens that have UV ink in them.
And then we also have a large bottle
and this is just eight ounces of glowing ink.
This stuff is an alcohol-based ink,
so it spreads really thinly.
And we're going to try using
a paintbrush to apply that
as well as this thing,
which lets you choose
what liquid you want to use
and then it sprays out just
like a can of spray paint.
First off, I think we need
to do some tests to see
what this ink looks like
under normal lighting conditions,
so we can see how different
it is when we use the black light.
These little ballpoint pens
that I have are pretty nifty
because not only
do they come with black-light ink,
they also come with a small
black light built right into the cap.
I can press this button,
and it lights right up.
This lets you write secret notes
that wouldn't otherwise be visible.
But if you and a friend
both have the pens,
you can write secret
notes to each other
and reveal them with the black light.
Now, for our first test,
I just wrote a little bit
on this white piece of paper.
And of course, a white piece of paper
is going to reflect the UV light pretty well.
We also have a much
larger black light
that we can use to try
and reveal our lettering.
That certainly makes it more legible,
at least in real life.
On camera, it really has
a hard time picking it up.
The biggest issue is that
the ink reflects in the same color
as our white piece of paper.
So let's try using
a piece of colored paper,
and see if we have a better result.
It's really easy to write
secret notes using these things
and I think, especially,
the best way to do it
would be to write a plain-text note
and then a secret note below that –
so you can see one note
when you have normal light,
and a secondary note when
you've got the black light added.
Personally, what I think
is one of the best uses for this
is if you have a long
or difficult password
that you really
struggle to remember,
you can write it down using the UV ink
and then write a distracting
fake note right above that.
So you've got a reason
to have it on your computer,
but you know that
if you forgot your password,
you have way to look it up
without it being broadcast to everyone.
Although these pens are
designed for writing on paper,
you may find you have success
writing on some other surfaces as well.
Let's try a few.
[Music]
Well we've tested on
a few different surfaces.
Let's see how permanent it is.
Let's grab a wet cloth,
and see if that scrubs off
or if it stays pretty
much where we put it.
[Music]
Sure seems to be
staying pretty well.
Of course, I'm only using water,
but that's not going anywhere.
I think it may have
worn down a little bit
from all of that scrubbing,
but not very much.
Let's try this stuff
on the back of my glove
where it says glove.
How about the smiley face on my arm?
[Music]
It rubs off of skin fairly well.
There's still a little bit of marks,
but I'm not sure if they
show up very well on camera.
Water doesn't do it.
I think it's an alcohol-based ink,
so let's see if we can
get it off with rubbing alcohol.
[Music]
It takes a little bit of effort,
but it does lift it off.
Of course, that could just be that
we're lifting the paint right off.
Let's try it on my glove.
Okay, that barely
touched that.
So, I'm going to say that even alcohol
doesn't do a very good job of removing it,
but it may do a good job
of removing the paint
that the ink is written on top of.
Let's see if it does anything
to the ink on my jeans.
Seems to be picking up
a little bit of it.
[Music]
It takes some of it out,
but it's definitely still there in part.
I've got this black poster board,
which is a piece of foam
with black paper on the outside,
and I discovered that the pens
work really well on this surface.
It shows up very nicely against the black –
kind of like it does on a glove.
Here, I've written the word
Sunshine with a sun shining out of it
because I have another test,
and that's to see if we can
look at this ink outside.
Sunlight has quite
a bit of UV rays in it,
and I'm wondering if that's enough
to let us see what we've written.
First impressions when I look at it
is that I can see something
and I'm not sure if that's from
where the pressure of the pen
was denting into the board
or if it's really reflecting the light.
Since I wasn't sure if the pen
had scratched into the board
or if I was seeing the ink itself,
I tried drawing
this square on my glove,
because the pen doesn't leave
physical marks in the gloves.
Let's see if we can see
that square out in the sunlight.
Right off the bat,
it looks like it's pretty visible.
It's even reflecting a little bit,
which makes me think that
the ink might not be dry yet.
I think this means
if you know what to look for,
this ink might be
visible in bright sunlight,
at least if it's freshly applied.
We know these pens are pretty cool
and they can write
on a lot of surfaces,
but let's see what we can do
with this bottle of ink.
This is a lot of ink.
I want to try applying it
in a few different methods.
First, I've got a paintbrush,
and I want to see what happens
if I just brush this onto
a few of the same surfaces.
[Music]
Let's try some of this on my glove.
It was extremely visible
with the pen on my glove.
I'm betting I have a similar
result with the brush.
[Music]
Wow!
That is a very bright glow!
Now, this stuff actually
has warnings on it saying,
don't put it on your skin.
But I'm going to try it anyway.
[Music]
I'd say that shows up quite a bit,
although, because I'm brushing it on
and this ink is really thin,
it does bleed a little bit through
the tiny little crevices in your skin.
Shiza.
Oops!
[Music]
Well, because I'm very clever,
I just managed to spill about
half an ounce of the liquid,
all over the workbench.
Given my test, this might stay
glowing under a black light
pretty much forever
until we repaint the surface –
not to mention, my gloves.
Amazingly, even with that much
of the ink, when the black light is off,
it looks pretty normal.
But now, I want to
see this in the sun as well.
So, let's try that out.
I would say that the sun
is definitely putting off
enough UV light that you can see this.
There's a clear change in color
from black to navy blue.
[Music]
Well, our ink glows
beautifully under our black light.
And it glows beautifully
when it spills on the table
and gets all over your gloves.
I want to see if
we can use it to spray
like a sort of
hidden secret graffiti.
So we're going to try
putting some of our ink
into this spray bottle.
This is a cool little thing
that uses an aerosol sprayer
to spray whatever you put
down in this glass jar.
And we're going to try it
with some of our glow ink.
That looks pretty cool.
Alright.
Let's see how well this thing works.
[Music]
It's spraying something.
Of course, my glove
is already glowing,
but that looks pretty neat.
[Music]
I'm not sure exactly
what it's doing to the paint
or not doing the paint.
Oops. I touched it earlier.
But Grant said it's okay,
so, you know...
[Music]
Ooh! That comes out a lot at a time.
Looks like it's getting
absorbed into the paint too.
That works pretty well.
It's not a super consistent spray,
but it was definitely spraying out.
And here's the thing:
I'm really bad at graffiti.
so I'm going to try making a stencil
and using that to spray onto stuff,
instead of just freehanding it.
[Music]
Our TKOR stencil –
this should be fun.
I think we'll be able to get
a few different uses out of that.
I made a little bridge connecting
to the cut-out part in the 'R.'
There's space on the top and bottom.
We'll see if that works.
A little bit of an experiment,
but either way, this should
give us what we're looking for:
a stencil, so we can spray
this logo onto stuff – like the wall.
Here goes.
[Music]
It worked!
It's not the cleanest stencil ever,
but that is definitely the logo.
[Music]
We tried using the stencil
on a t-shirt as well,
but it kind of got
absorbed into the cloth
and doesn't reflect very much.
It's still visible a little bit,
but not nearly as well
as it works on the wall.
[Music]
Guys, we want to take a minute
to talk about the sponsor for today's video,
Audible.
Audible has the largest
collection of audiobooks available,
and it is a great service.
I love Audible.
The thing I listen to the most
is science fiction and fantasy books,
but I do like to branch out.
And whenever I do,
Audible's got me covered.
They've got all sorts
of things to listen to.
There are two places I prefer
to listen to Audible the most.
The first is when I'm driving somewhere.
Long drives can
get kind of boring to me.
But if I'm listening
to something good,
I look forward to it.
The other is when I'm working on a build –
I'm making something in my workshop –
and there's some tedious parts to it.
Like if you're ever just sanding something...
But throw in a pair of headphones,
and suddenly, you are
taken away to whatever land
your audiobook takes place in.
It really makes it
a much better experience.
Audible also keeps track
of what you're listening to
and where in the track you are.
So, if you switch devices,
it's not a problem.
I can go from listening
on my phone in my workshop
to my computer on my desktop,
and it's not going
to make any difference.
To start your free 30-day trial,
and receive a free audiobook,
go to AUDIBLE.COM/THEKINGOFRANDOM
or text the text "THEKINGOFRANDOM" to 500-500.
Guys, the fun doesn't end here.
We've got more for you to see.
The box at the top will transport
you directly to our last video,
and you should go check that out.
The box at the bottom
will show you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching now.
And this bomb here in the middle
will subscribe to the channel.
That way,
you'll never miss a video.
Don't forget to ring the bell.
And we'll see in the next one.
Talk to you then.